hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
hello Ashley ed nur has a YouTube
channel people make sure to check it out
how to's and Morgan and Ashley lifestyle
fitness it's great yeah go check her out
she also has an Instagram I follow her
so you should too today we're gonna
watch the second trailer for Jennifer
Lawrence movie called red Sparrow red
spoiler because the first one came out
already oh I watch it with some other
chick no I watched it with John I think
okay that's fine who's like a chick okay
patron the day shocked and I got some at
Lyle's that Lyle's has been a longtime
patron rarely responds to my messages
but he's a sexy guy give you a full shot
at after the video my friend let's check
it out you ready Ashley I'm so ready so
you know nothing about this
I was told to take a mental hotel he
said he was an enemy of the state take
off your dress
in exchange my mother look at the doctor
she made him
instead they cut his throat
there could be no
so they gave me a choice die or become a
sparrow
[Music]
with you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
also hot the only man cuz of where you
can do for them will quit me and make
these men weak you trust a word that
comes out of her mouth
here's something else
this is compromise she will be
eliminated
you belong to him they won't ever let go
how family
[Music]
nipple chills I think this looks so fun
I'm excited to see you in March
coming up fun I think yeah looks like a
fun movie really fun I mean I think so
fun seems like a weird word to describe
it I don't know I had fun watching this
trailer have fun watching it - yeah it's
a spy thriller yeah yeah no it looks
really what's cool to me about it - that
I thought this trailer communicated
really well is that it's also a
character piece at the same time yes she
has like a soul and she's like you know
battling if she's like she's a killer
yes but she has a heart so we already
don't like her cuz you've seen this
journey of her being thrown into being a
sparrow
whatever that is like some type of
Russian soldiers v their goal is to make
you just this lethal warrior who has no
emotion and just does the mission and
the job so I like the fact that we're
gonna get to explore the training
sequences there see her go into the
field but also it sounds like she's
gonna become a master of something in
there are they love were they using each
other we don't know there's so many
questions and she also has the emotional
turmoil of which side should she really
be on in here I feel like it's gonna be
like this cool plot mixed with a cool
characters journey yeah of her having to
decide what kind of life she wants to
live in the kind of human being she
wants to ultimately be in the end which
is great for Lawrence what I'm saying
right now is that I think the twist is
gonna be like when she's in love with
who with the name joel edgerton yeah
he's awesome I think that like you know
they're in love yes and then I I feel
like at some point like is he gonna like
kill her is he really in on something
and he's trying to manipulate her like
that
we're in there if they're gonna
double-cross each other because she
doesn't he doesn't want her to be a red
sparrow that's what I got from the
trailer she doesn't want her to do that
maybe when he does pull her out there is
some ultimate game plan he has like who
do you really trust company the twists
and turns look like it's gonna be a
roller coaster and also Jennifer
Lawrence even though she's in the x-men
franchise and even though she did Hunger
Games the fact that she's doing these
fight scenes that are just involved like
her fists looks really awesome it's
believable with her yeah not like too
dainty of like a girl but like she's
looks like she like it could actually
happen yeah I don't know she seems like
a tough cookie alive she's like she
could get tough you know I don't really
believe her Russian accent but I feel
like I could get past that like I feel
like in a movie context I wouldn't be
like oh my god I can't believe
yeah it looks shot really cool and I
like how the trailer capitalizes more on
story and suspense than action and yeah
I feel like it's gonna be one hell of a
thrill ride hopefully this is hopefully
this is really cool man maybe she's got
another franchise on our hands
oh you think so like the Bourne Identity
yeah she dies at the end
and then joel edgerton continues it and
no one cares we're wrapping this up Matt
Lyle's my friend dude you need to hit us
up more on patreon man a lot of people
message us a lot of people comment to us
you have been pledged to us since the
very beginning and you never ask us any
questions or give us requests or nothing
Matt I'm starting to get mad at you
we'll take the reward tier they use and
the money you pledge will constantly I'm
sure but we know we want to feel like
we're earning it you don't want us to do
anything we are okay with that I have to
say to look like a good guy who
subscribe to the real rejects people
click that notification about they get
notified every time wash Lee ed nur is
on the youtubes as well go check out her
channel link in the description box
become a patron eject today it'll be
worth your time maybe